[musique]
comme un ajustement Quand notre
l'artillerie frappe très bien
alors de telles émotions arrivent parfois
surtout quand on a une semaine de mauvais temps
personne ne vole, personne ne te tire dessus
après, il y a des jours où tout va bien
l'artillerie commence à rouler
travailler très efficacement Et puis directement
Parfois les émotions dépassent les bornes, on crie même
impressionné
bassin
[musique]
ils ne peuvent pas accomplir de tâches militaires
effectuer
si nous avions
drones militaires de la police
combattu l'ennemi beaucoup plus efficacement
Ils sont tous saisonniers et peuvent voler
la nuit et là-bas c'est presque exclu
il y a beaucoup de facteur humain dans ces drones
à cause du facteur humain, ils ne peuvent pas voler
sous la pluie, sous la neige, etc., pourquoi parle-t-on de
Bakhmut, on perd du temps car c'est l'hiver la nuit
nous sommes longs presque 50% du temps
nous utilisons de manière inefficace
[musique]
je pense qu'il vole toujours, ce qui est hostile et
le plus souvent, nous sommes aussi battus
les petits drones abattent également les anti-drones
C'est juste que ça ne sert à rien
plus de pitié
accroche-toi dans le champ de vision et commence ici
les télécommandes tombent et tu commences à tout comprendre
que ce n'est pas un poisson qui est à 30 km
un singe se tient dans la tranchée, étouffé par lui
J'ai juste pointé le pistolet sous toi et
essayant d'abattre son drone parce que
ils pensent que c'est une divination
[musique]